[Music]
i also have a glass of wine
double fisting no no you're not
cheers before we start okay number one
dad
it says number one see that i love it
i'm gonna play around right now see now
can i be honest with with
with you right now about this game this
part is not fun at all because i'm just
holding on
and i'm just interested you're dying
because you're bad no it's just i'm
holding it waiting for the thing to
happen
jump oh i got a hit
and electrocuted great died nine times
so far so we decided we thought we might
pick up a different game
but i like this one oh okay
what sentence ends in butt none of them
right
so you interrupted me so
it says hit wow i'm gonna absolutely
kick your ass
okay there's obviously something to do
here that's not
it's like just because you bring the
controller closer to your face doesn't
mean it makes it easy
hey we both jumped one two
no okay we're gonna double stop is what
we're gonna do okay how do you do that
well you just you count to three in real
life and then you hit the jump
one two three okay oh no remember
these those things you messed up no no
no you go
no you go jump and then you hit the
circle together remember that thing
where do you go here we go one two three
okay one two three jump and oh
yeah baby johnny
johnny figures it out with teamwork
johnny good break
teamwork mostly johnny but also
you helped too johnny and jenna knows it
yeah that's you jenny
[Music]
well i can't really care if you're just
doing this
did i ever tell you that the day that i
found out
magic wasn't real when i was a kid was
the worst
day of my childhood and i cried the
whole day yeah
i know what was the worst day of your
childhood
uh i'll let you know i'll let you know
when it happens
the deepest question
whoa it really is magic
so what's going on here i didn't listen
it's fine this is you in movies too
what you just oh that's crazy dude i
watch the movies for real
no you do bits during them and then you
get frustrated that you don't know
what's happening because
well we don't need to tell them
everything about our personal life right
i think they probably could have guessed
that without me did i do that
dude she was on like meth right there
you're saying she like it's about you
she she it's she
there we go i did it i did it
i did it we need to make a shirt called
that says ouchie on it for you
no she says no she doesn't like money
folks
oh he did it yeah this you know this is
fun dude now we're
this is where guys welcome welcome to
flex avenue now we're really going
[ __ ] 100 miles an hour
on flex avenue because i'll tell you
what dude last time it was [ __ ]
because last time we were just skating
on pipes and now we're swinging through
the jungle
hikes pipes who thinks that someone even
if i said pikes
who wouldn't know that i meant pipes in
that situation shook up your words quite
often so i like
finding you in the [ __ ] ups i do hot
what
we have fun i'm not garbage at this game
dude
i'm really not i'm just 41 and i don't
you know
don't play it okay that means you're
garbage at it no
hold on babe we have to do it together
okay let me tell you what to do okay
okay so it starts this game honestly
starts with listening to me well
how to listen i spend my whole day doing
that
just listening to you you're
disintegrating
oh okay so you were looking at me and
you jumped off
you jumped to your dad look around first
what you're going to want to do is look
around look around
okay now what you're going to want to do
is wait you see that little coil thing
on the thing you're going to want to
jump and dash and then hit r1 because
it's far away
jump jump dash r1 all right
okay jump dash r1 there we go now let it
go
and we're golden dude now you're close
to me you're closer to me
keep it moving keep it moving keep it
moving
keep there i am there we are look at
that
we love each other in this game
okay i wore the nasa shirt
in honor of in honor of the richest guy
you don't have to ever do something in
honor to the richest
more like a space thing happens so i
wore my space shirt
it's way different i think i flew a
[ __ ] big [ __ ] to the moon why are
there bottoms so
hefty they're squirrels you know they
look like
pears they're scored of course parents
repairs when they stand up
that's not the weird part the weird part
is they have no [ __ ]
no the weird part is that you're looking
at a squirrel's [ __ ] expecting
i looked at the [ __ ] area because you
were saying
why are they so hefty on the bottom so i
looked and they have no no
no no no genitalia which is weird and
then also
no nuts which is crazy weird for
squirrels because squirrels have nuts
in their hands in between their legs and
also in their
in their mouths the squirrel nut thing
is about
the nuts that they eat and berry not the
ones
i know squirrels have always at least
two nuts and then also sometimes one
more
not in their mouth you know what i'm
saying
actually if a squirrel had always has
two nuts
and then also could it even have one
more nut in their mouth
and i don't mean it it sounds gross but
i don't mean i don't mean it to be
gross are you having a stroke
[Laughter]
down at flex avenue avenue we listened
to you guys
down at flex avenue we listened to you
guys
so we just put those subtitles on for
that ass
okay back and look at the controller
nine times before i start
there we go our agent was seduced by its
power and switched sides very
interesting so now we can read it that's
such a good idea whoever that was
dude you guys we listen to you thank you
guys we listen to you and we put the
subtitles on
that's what you get when you come on
down to flex avenue
can i tell them the cute thing you did
today no dude that's i'm a man
okay but i'm a man though and they
i was walking into the store and i was
talking to the ladies
at the store and then they were like
turn around
and then i turned around and chris was
right outside in the front with flowers
so he drove up to the store
he saw on my location that i was right
down the street and he got me flowers
and drove into the store it was so cute
and then he came in and watched me try
on outfits all right i mean
dude yeah it was okay it was it was cute
i was going to that store already i love
new christmas is so
thoughtful
l2 and r2 are how i get the jellies
no i never thought waking up today i
would hear that sentence what the frick
i'm mormon
teamwork dude it takes two and thank you
for coming on down a red
evil what is it called people flex
avenue
where are you i'm shooting in some
things over here
all right is that what you have to do
sweetheart
i have no idea all right oh wow
i hope we have to do that
right so let's make sure that's the fair
point
get the sap where it needs to go right
um babe yeah
i think i'm gonna be like in a movie i
think you're gonna want to see this
look go to the [ __ ] thing here go to
where i go
you see where the blue thing is oh i got
something in my hand oh is that the same
thing i'm gonna do like we're in a movie
um i
think you're gonna want to come see this
now do the sap
babe what's up i think you're going to
want to back up
no the the character
here we go you're either the
smartest person i ever met or the
craziest son of a [ __ ] i've ever seen
in my life i'm gonna do it like we're in
the rock
please perfect did i
suck everything up go hit it shoot that
shoot that and keep shooting it oh great
yeah you did no now you're [ __ ] let me
just die
no no no when in doubt i could have just
done that
all right
i don't have a sub button yet does that
mean we make money during it
yeah we got to play like [ __ ] 900
years first or something
we're just having fun go dude go to the
oh why would you be
doing that i kind of because that's
obviously not and then just wanted to
get out
no don't shoot zap into the wind don't
shoot sap
that's like that john denver song or
what's that guys need to be told that
gross
okay i did it and you had to do it twice
why do you say wow like that like you're
falling off a building i don't know
why do you do a bunch of the stuff you
do oh that was an auger
stone cold slam all right we gotta get
that down obviously
hit sap under it dude johnny thinks
about it
where
baby you're just absolutely doing
nothing oh yeah
really you want to rethink that dude get
the sap under the thing
turn around where i am looking okay
under the thing and shoot that so it
comes down
johnny is basically a video game guys
welcome to flex avenue we're going to
sap up this gate
we're going to wait for my fiancee to
get up here and just step up this gate
now she's taking too long and that's
okay honestly because this video game
isn't going anywhere here on flex avenue
we're just
turns out here on flex avenue this half
of the gate ain't the thing to do
yeah no you have to hit it on the yellow
part though step on that follow button
okay okay now i know what to do okay go
right on the thing and hit the r1 and
start swinging the baby starts swinging
dude well i need to
know you already did it you already did
it okay so i have to start swinging
start swinging dude okay jenny swings a
lot
okay yes you're scaring me
relax
but what we got to do is first of all
it's just a game is it right oh [ __ ]
it's just a game okay no i don't
don't stay there beautiful now i would
just tell her for a little bit relax in
each stage see what happens if you jump
ahead
you're like what am i going to do next
and that's how you pump your death
great life rules babe yeah now i want
you to relax
relax there's no reason you don't need
to be going anywhere honestly i'm just
going to sit back with my wine while you
do no
okay now now we're at the next step
though we're at the next step
no i know but now we're now it's time
that was game time
now we get back to now we got to go
there right because that's the next
step you stay there right here so i'm
gonna jump onto this
there we go johnny next step now
we accomplished something great now hold
on
if you fall i get really i'm going to
get really
no no you can do it no but i would
prefer
but i know you can do it okay i believe
in you
if you fall we're toast
that's all you got to do is just jump on
it there you go now wait now wait
now jump off it yes dude
i'm proud of you thank you you can't see
the teardrops but they're there
dude i'm proud of you thanks okay no no
chill not chill okay cause look at me
look at god look at god dude oh [ __ ]
you're out of here no just look at god
dude what do you mean look at god
i'm saying that's like what rap rappers
say but it's all good
you're 41 in white there's a lot of
white rappers
it's like two how would we make the left
side go down
that's just from a physics standpoint
how would we make the left side go now
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
physics
if we want the left side to go down what
would we do
let's do some extra sap over here babe
maybe under that one under the left one
to make it go down
that's the there you go physics
physics baby physics did i do it well no
look at me
look at god he's not even there yet
i'm a rapper no you're we're gonna stop
that right okay but you're not
hitting anything that needs to be hit
okay
i'm kind of distracted but that's fine
[ __ ] but
but now what you use my screen too
can you just blow it all up so i can
start over no because i'm already on it
if i blow it up or what who cares die
who cares
okay now we now we just see the fruits
of our labor
chain reaction this here we go all right
hey
kristen you might want to move back
whoa wow do we just go oh
there's something obviously we've got to
do here yeah yeah
okay i bet it just was bad
oh do you have to go to the bathroom
jesus this guy's really just coming
after me it's not very fair is it
i did hit him in the back okay you got
it once
oh god what kind of bee has it needs a
buzz saw
got him
oh god is he [ __ ] busting he's just
oh oh i got a bunch of them
i mean couldn't sound like he's busting
dude
oh dude he saw me
okay where are you yep sorry stop him up
we're losing until we're running out of
time i think i saved him
all right we're halfway done okay oh man
suck them up babe
all right yep nice and soft
dude come on down to flex avenue and see
how step these bees out oh
[ __ ]
let's get through that box okay well
we're almost done here on flex avenue we
gotta
nice did we do it i don't know let's see
we did it
that was nice oh that's cool dalia you
and your fiancee are wonderful to watch
the video games thanks chris
cute that's sweet we did it
bring them to me
oh no guys just when we thought it was
over
maybe it's over hold on what time is it
did we do it first
we did it for about an hour and a half
yeah
yeah let's see well we can come back
yeah we can you know we can always
come back and we'll come back next time
and we're going to be asleep we're going
to be asleep tonight we'll just be like
he keeps calling me back here's a racist
[ __ ]
key dictionary is a very dangerous
operation
reminding us you want to see my quads i
have pants on i have pants on this style
one person i have pants on but dude
they're real thick trust me
[ __ ] in the meantime dude if people are
bored with this cut scene tell them how
uh big my traps are who the people on
the thing tell them how big my traps are
tell who
our twitchers all right that's good
we'll do the rest another time huh i
mean [ __ ] it you know what i mean you
guys are awesome
thank you look at the camera look
you guys are awesome thanks for
streaming twitching with us
we're gonna go watch some [ __ ] murder
documentaries because that's all we
watch
uh have a good time how do we get out of
here though dude now we got to turn up
but remember dude
just because we're we're turning it off
doesn't we got to make sure that we know
it's off because it was still on right
now so don't say
those racial slurs what do you end it
with that every time oh yeah
racial stuff i know i know but i'm just
saying be careful and don't say anything
like don't tell people where the money
is hidden okay
but we've got to turn it off but we're
still on air dude so don't
say anything cancelable or sharing this
now hold on a second hit the share
button
baby don't do anything everything is
fine what do we do
relax don't tell them don't mention how
calvin is really a hologram
[Music]
you